THIS IS THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE IN ROOM FOUR FOUR
SEVEN SERGEANTS PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELCOME TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING JUST A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
AS WE GO OVER FIRST.
WE HAVE FOUR ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY TO SENATE BILLS TO
ASSEMBLY BILLS THAT ARE BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE HEARS
BILLS IN FINE ORDER WE'RE GOING
TO MAKE AN EXCEPTION TODAY THANK
YOU MISTER CHIU.
OUR FIRST BILL TODAY WILL BE --
ITEM NUMBER --
THREE A. B. EIGHT TWENTY NINE
BEFORE YOU START WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE WALDRON BLOOM
CABALLERO GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE GRAYSON GRAYSON
HERE LACKEY REVERSE.
REAVIS HERE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HERE.
OKAY --
WELCOME MR CHIU BANK MANAGER AND
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR
INDULGENCE AS WELL CENTER
JACKSON'S INDULGENCE I HAVE TO
ALSO CHAIR COMMITTEE THAT I WILL
BE RUNNING TO IN A SECOND BUT OF
THIS IS A BILL HELPING TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESS AND HOUSING
CRISIS THAT I KNOW THIS
COMMITTEE KNOWS.
ABOUT WELL IN SOME PARTS OF OUR
STATE THERE ARE AFFORDABLE IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN DELAYED OR STOPPED.
WHERE PROJECTS ARE REQUIRED TO
GET A LETTER OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
FROM AN INDIVIDUAL CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN WHOSE DISTRICT A
PROJECT MAY BE LOCATED?
AS A CONDITION FOR RECEIVING
FUNDING WITHOUT THIS LETTER A
PROJECT CAN NOT GET INTO A
PIPELINE FOR FUNDING.
AND MANY OF THESE PROJECTS ALSO
RECEIVE STATE FUNDING AND SO AS
A RESULT OF THIS CURRENT POLICY
PROJECTS ARE BEING HALTED OR
STALLED SINCE.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T GET THE SIGN
OFF OF A SINGLE LOCAL ELECTED
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE
OF AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT LETTER AS
A THRESHOLD CONDITION.
LOCAL OFFICIALS WILL STILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO INFLUENCE
PROJECTS TO THE PLANNING PROCESS
BUT THEY WILL NOT HAVE A POCKET
VETO.
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER
TO MY WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING ON LAWLER WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY --
THESE LIVING AUDIT REQUIREMENTS
CREATE AN ARBITRARY BARRIER TO
PROJECTS BEFORE AN APPLICATION
FOR THE PROJECT HAS EVEN BEEN
FILED --
THIS BILL WOULD PUT A STOP TO
THAT PRACTICE ANALOG QUICKLY
NEEDED SUPPORT OF HOUSING
PROJECTS TO MOVE FORWARD --
AND WITHOUT WILL SPREE SPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN TO CAST ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OTHERS.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING THAT ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
WHO THE BILL?
THANK YOU WHERE MANY QUESTIONS.
US SING NONE WE HAVE --
DO YOU LIKE TO CLOSE APPRECIATE
ASK YOU APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M JUST
BEEN INTERJECT ONE SMALL THING
HERE I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
PERSIAN OF ANI WHO HAS WORKED ON
YOUR BILL THIS IS HER LAST BILL
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHE'S MY
FELLOW.
SHE IS A FABULOUS JOB FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SO EVERYBODY.
THIS IS THE BEST COMMITTEE
HOUSES I'VE SEEN IN THE MANY.
LOTS.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SECRETARY --
CALLED.
THE MOTIONS TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM
CABALLERO.
COVER YOUR AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON GRAYSON RIVAS
RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I THINK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEASURES OUT.
SIX ZERO A NEXT WILL HELP ITEM
NUMBER --
TWO SENATOR JACKSON SP FOUR
SIXTY FIVE WELCOME SENATOR.
GOOD MORNING HOME TEASE ME MATT
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
YOU KNOW AS WE ARE LOOKING AND
SO MANY OF US AND I KNOW THE
CHAIR OF PARTICULARLY --
AT THE IMPACTS OF THE WILDFIRES
THAT WE'RE HAVING --
IN CALIFORNIA AND HAD LAST YEAR.
OF WHICH COST LIVES AND
DESTROYED THOUSANDS OF HOMES.
A ONE OF THE QUESTIONS IS WHAT
CAN AND MUST WE DO TO TRY --
TO EITHER PREVENT OR MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS OF THESE FIRES GOING
FORWARD WE TALK ABOUT --
ALL SORTS OF NEW FOREST
MANAGEMENT ISSUES WE TALK ABOUT
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE. ONE
OF THE THINGS THOUGH THAT WE
HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED WE NEED TO DO
IS WE NEED TO HARDEN NOT JUST
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
UTILITY COMPANIES.
BUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF OUR
OWN HOMES.
BECAUSE THAT BECOMES AT MANY
POINTS THE KEY SIR THE FULCRUM
FOR THESE FIRES.
AND SO THIS IS A BILL F. I. S.
BEFORE SIXTY FIVE THAT WHILE
FIRE SAFETY FINANCE ACT.
WHICH AUTHORIZES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO EXPAND THEIR
PROPERTY ASSESSED CLEAN ENERGY
OR PACE PROGRAMS. TO ALLOW
PROPERTY OWNERS TO FINANCE THE
INSTALLATION AWHILE FIRE SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THEIR HOMES AND
BUSINESSES WHAT WE MIGHT CALL
HARDENING.
OUR HOMES --
AND I'D FIRST LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE THIS --
THIS BILL IS RELATIVELY NEW I
WAS LOOKING FOR A WAY WHAT CAN
WE DO TO TO HELP PEOPLE A GET
RID OF SHAKE ROOFS OR DOUBLE
PANE THEIR WINDOWS OR CHEST
BASIC THINGS.
THAT WILL HELP REDUCE OF THESE
FIRES ARE HOPEFULLY HELP PRODUCE
THESE FIRES FROM DESTROYING
HOMES I WAS USING THIS MORNING I
THINK ON NPR THE NUMBER OF HOMES
A PERCENTAGE OF HOMES.
THAT HAVE BEEN REBUILT.
US SINCE THESE FIRES IS TO AND
PART OF THE REASON A OF COURSE
IS LACK OF INSURANCE ARE UNDER
INSURANCE THE EXTENT OF THESE
FIRES.
BUT PART OF IT IS FOR THOSE
WHOSE HOMES ARE STILL REMAINING.
WE NEED TO HELP THOSE PEOPLE
MAKE ADJUSTMENTS OUGHT TO THE
STRUCTURES TO HELP PREVENT THOSE
STRUCTURES BEING DESTROYED GOING
FORWARD SO I WANT TO THANK --
THE COMMITTEE FREE FOR THEIR
ASSISTANCE FOR YOUR ASSISTANCE
AND I THINK THE MOST RECENT SET
OF AMENDMENTS --
ARE KEY CONSUMER SAFEGUARDS AND
ENSURE THAT WAS STRIKING THE
RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN PROTECTING
CONSUMERS AND USING PACE AS A
TOOL TO HARDEN OUR EXISTING
HOMES.
AGAINST THE THREAT OF WILDFIRES
I KNOW WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
PEOPLE WHO OPPOSE THIS BILL THEY
DON'T LIKE PACE.
THIS BILL ISN'T ABOUT WITH YOU
LIKE PACE OR DON'T LIKE PACE
THIS IS A BILL THAT SAYS WALL
PACES STILL THERE AND I KNOW THE
CHURN PARTICULARS BEEN WORKING
TO MAKE REFORMS.
BUT WHILE THAT MONEY IS THERE
LET'S ADD A A CRITERIA THAT
ALLOWS FOR PACE FUNDS TO BE USED
FOR HARDENING OF HOMES.
I EXISTING HOMES NOT NEW HOMES
THAT WE HAVE TO REBUILD THIS IS
A PREVENTIVE ACT AND JOB --
I APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR IT'S
ASSISTANCE WITH THAT'S NOT I
DON'T HAVE TO GO INTO THE FACT
THAT WE'VE HAD ALL THESE
WILDFIRES AND THOUSANDS OF HOMES
HAVE BEEN LOST.
BUT WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SAY IS
THAT -- WE
NEED TO WE NEED TO FOCUS ON THIS
ASPECT OF THE DISCUSSION AS WELL
AS HARDENING THE GRADE IN THESE
OTHER THINGS SO.
IT TURNS OUT THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL INC A MAINTAINED TO LIST
OF UPGRADES THAT HOMEOWNERS AND
HIGH FIRE HAZARD AREAS SHOULD
UNDERTAKE TO MAKE THEIR HOMES
MORE RESILIENT TO WILDFIRES.
INCLUDING AS I MENTIONED GETTING
RID OF WHO WOULD --
OR ROUTE A SHINGLE ROOFS AND
WOOD SIGHTINGS.
BUT OF COURSE THE COST OF THESE
CAN BE.
QUITE PROHIBITIVE I KNOW WHEN WE
REPLACED OUR SHINGLED ROOF IT
WAS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
UP BUT IT'S NECESSARY YOUR
INVESTMENT HOLE FOR MANY PEOPLE
YOUR HOME IS YOUR PRIMARY
INVESTMENT.
AND BECAUSE OF A THE YEAH
INCIDENTS OF FIRES AND THEIR
IMPACTS OF THIS IS THE KIND OF
THING WE NEED TO BE FOCUSING OUR
ATTENTION ON ITS HOMEOWNERS WE
ARE EMPOWERED THERE ARE THINGS
WE CAN DO.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THEM SO I
WOULD LIKE TO ALLOW HOMEOWNERS
AND BUSINESSES TO TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THIS PROGRAM.
A TO FINANCE SOME OF THESE ARE
HOME HARDENING UPGRADES RIGHT
NOW PAYS CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
ENERGY AND WATER EFFICIENCY
PROJECTS AND SEISMIC UPGRADES
AND I WILL TELL YOU THOSE ARE
ALL IMPORTANT NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
BUT AS WE LOOK AT THE
DEVASTATION OF THE SHOULD BE
ADDING THIS KIND OF CRITERIA --
TO THIS OPPORTUNITY TO GET SOME
PAYS FOR ANYTHING AND SO.
WITH THAT I KNOW AS I MENTIONED
THAT THE CHAIR IS WORKING ON
REFORMING PACE I HAVE NO.
QUARREL WITH THAT I THINK THAT
THAT WORK IS IMPORTANT AND I
KNOW HAS BEEN THE SUBJECT OF
LOTS OF DISCUSSION.
BUT AGAIN WALL PACE IS THERE
LET'S ADD THIS VERY IMPORTANT
CRITERIA TO HELP EMPOWER PEOPLE
TO TECH THEIR HOMES ARE IN THESE
EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES SO.
SPECIFICALLY THIS MEASURE
INCORPORATES ITS OWN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS BY AMONG OTHER
THINGS ENSURING REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
BUSINESS OVERSIGHT.
REQUIRING PATIENT MINISTRY TO
REACH TO REPORT ON WILDLIFE
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
FINANCED UNDER THE BILL.
LIMIT FIRE HARDENING THROUGH
PACE TO PROPERTIES THAT ARE
LOCATED IN VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY SONGS TARGETING THIS
FUNDING FOR THAT WHERE IT'S
GOING TO DO THE BEST.
A BEST AND AND HIGHEST USE
LIMITING THE TYPES OF PROJECTS
ELIGIBLE FOR PACE. TO THOSE
IDENTIFIED ALREADY IDENTIFIED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION.
AND PLACING A TEN YEAR SUNSET.
ON THIS ASPECT OF PACE SO THAT
OUR FUTURE GENERATIONS OF OUR
FUTURE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW HOW WELL
FIRE HARDENING OF THE OF THE
SPACE PROGRAM HAS FUNCTION
WITHOUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
WITNESS SUPPORT CERTAINLY PAUL
MAY SO THAT IT FOREST TRUST ALSO
VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF I YOU
PREFER THE SENATOR BRING THIS
FORWARD AND HE DID A VERY GOOD
JOB OF LAYING OUT MUCH THE
CONTACTS.
WE CAN DO.
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT OP FUELS
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER INCENTIVES
FOR THE WOOD PRODUCTSINDUSTRY
IN THESE VARIOUS BILLS ARE
MOVING FORWARD THIS YEAR AND WE
SHOULD BE DOING ALL THOSE THINGS.
BUT WHEN THE HOMES THEMSELVES
ARE THE FUEL.
WE WILL NEVER SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
AND WHILE WE HAVE GOOD BUILDING
STANDARDS NOW.
WE ALSO HAVE MORE THAN A MILLION
HOMES OUT IN THESE HIGH RISK
AREAS THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE
THESE MODERN BUILDING STANDARDS
I MEAN.
THE CHAIR HAS MANY OF THESE AND
HER HALL EARNED HER DISTRICT YOU
DID HAVE.
WELL THERE STILL ARE SOME AND
THE NUGGETS ARE LOOKING AROUND
LAKE COUNTY AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE NEVER GOING TO
HAVE. TEN FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO GO OUT AND FIX THEIR
HIGH RISK OF FACTORS ON THEIR
HOMES UNLESS WE MAKE SOME SORT
OF FINANCING AVAILABLE.
OFTEN WILL BRING A MULTIPLE
BENEFITS TO BUILD UP GREATER
ENERGY EFFICIENCY OF THE ROOF
WITH THE FOR THE SAME TIME BUT
WE NEED TO BRING THESE TOOLS
FORWARD BECAUSE WE'LL NEVER
WE'LL NEVER SOLVE OUR HOME LOSS
PROBLEM WITHOUT MAKING THE HOMES
MORE DEFENSIBLE.
WE INCURRED YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN A
SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR OF MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE CHRISTY ABOUT
MOMMY HALF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WERE
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE I WOULD JUST SAY IT IS A
COMPLEX PROBLEM.
THIS IS ONE PART IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ZONES ARE UNDER
THREAT.
AND MAYBE IMPROVEMENTS WOULD
MAKE NO DIFFERENCE FOR NOT ALSO
MANAGING OUR FORESTS OF BECAUSE
THESE FIRES ARE BURNING AT THE
INTENSITIES WE'VE NEVER SEEN
BEFORE SO WE'RE VERY PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
I KNOW THIS COMMITTEE HAS
GRAPPLED WITH WHAT DO WE DO
ABOUT THESE HOMES IN THESE
WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACES --
AND THIS IS ONE IMPORTANT STEP
ONE OF MANY THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
LUCAS FOR EXAMPLE HAVE THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AMBER PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THE BILL BUT ALSO
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE CAL THE
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES THAT
ARRIVED TO STAY OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS THE SEEMS LIKE A
NATURAL EXPANSION OF THE PACER
FINANCING PROGRAM THINK VERY.
MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M CATHERINE
GARCIA ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS ROGERS WITH
MY GREEN ENERGY FUND RIGHT HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT I AS WAS
MENTIONED THE WILD AN URBAN
INTERFACE PLAN CALLS FOR
SPECIALIZED VENTS AND WINDOWS.
AND OTHER THINGS TO SLOW THE
SPREAD OF FIRE AND WE THINK THAT
THIS IS A A FANTASTIC WAY TO
EXPAND THE USE IS A PACE TO
ALLOW.
EXISTING HOMES TO REALIZE THE
SAME TYPE OF FIRE RESILIENCY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MARK LET YOU KNOW BEHALF OVER
NEW FINANCIAL ALSO IN SUPPORT
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR BRING
THESE FORWARD AND THE
RECOGNITION THAT PACE IS ABOUT
OVER FINANCING PRODUCT.
FOR MANY HOMEOWNERS WHO NEED TO
DO THESE TYPE OF IMPROVEMENTS AS
FOR LIVE OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS LEXI HOWARD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ESCROW
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE ASSOCIATION.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO OFFER MY
THANKS TO THE SENATOR FOR HER
WORK ON THIS INTO YOU CHAIR FOR
YOUR WORK ON PACE --
WE DON'T DISLIKE PACE WE
RECOGNIZE IT SERVES CONSUMERS
WELL WHEN IT'S DONE RESPONSIBLY.
BUT THERE ARE PLACES THAT WE
HAVE SEEN OUR ESCROW PEOPLE WHEN
THEY HAVE BUYERS AND SELLERS IN
THEIR OFFICES SURPRISED FOR THE
FIRST TIME THAT THEY HAVE TO PAY
THEIR PACE.
ASSESSMENT IN FULL IN ORDER TO
COMPLETE A TRANSACTION WE HAVE
LENDERS WHO CANNOT RECOVER.
WHEN THERE IS A PACE LOAN PLACED
ON THERE ON A PROPERTY AFTER
THEY HAVE ORIGINATED THE LOAN
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO CONTINUE CONSIDER THEN THE
UNDERWRITING?
AT HOUSE FIRST LIEN PRIORITY AND
THE CAPE FOR FUND THAT IS THE
PACE LOSS RESERVE FUND IS NOT
AVAILABLE BEFORE SECOND
MORTGAGES ONLY FOR FIRST.
SO WE ARE.
RESPECTFUL IN OUR OPPOSITION
MANY OF OUR MEMBERS ARE IN FIRE
AFFECTED AREAS AND WE UNDERSTAND
THE VALUE OF PACE WE DO NO TO
THAT PACE AS AN ENERGY EFFICIENT
[inaudible]
A IMPROVEMENT DOES INCLUDE UNDER
PRESENT STATUTE THE ABILITY TO
REPLACE ROOFS AND WINDOWS AMONG
OTHER THINGS WE ARE CONCERNED
WHEN WE EXPAND THAT TO THINGS
LIKE.
ROADS AND ACCESS AND FENCES AND
OTHER THINGS PARTICULARLY IN THE
REALM OF INSURANCE THERE IS AN
OPEN QUESTION RIGHT NOW ABOUT
HOUSES THAT HAVE BURNED THAT HAD
PIECE ASSESSMENTS.
AND WHAT HAPPENS TO THE VALUE OF
THOSE ASSESSMENTS THOSE
BORROWERS STILL HAVE THOSE TAX
COLLECTIONS ON THE TAX ROLLS.
AND COME.
APRIL TENTH AND DECEMBER FOR BE
PAYING TAXES ON THOSE AND THEIR
TAXES INCREASED MARKEDLY WE
DON'T KNOW HOW THAT WILL BE
DEALT WITH BETWEEN THE PACE
PROVIDERS.
AND THE HOMEOWNERS SO
RESPECTFULLY WE ARE IN FAVOR OF
PACE WHEN DONE RESPONSIBLY VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT IT BEING
EXPANDED AT A TIME WHEN THERE'S
SO MUCH THAT IS DYNAMIC.
AND THANK YOU VERY BUT I'M WITH
US [inaudible]
NOT.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MY NAME
IS ANNA BUT I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS --
I'D LIKE TO START BY BEING CLEAR
THE REALTORS SUPPORT RESPONSIBLE
PACE FUNDING.
AS WELL AS THE EFFORT BY SENATOR
JACKSON TO THINK OUTSIDE THE BOX
THE POTENTIAL USE THE PACE
PROGRAM AS A WAY. FOR HOMEOWNERS
TO FINANCE THIS HOME HARDENING --
WHICH CAN AID --
IN MAKING AYE CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING STOCK MORSE SAFE AND
MORE RESILIENT AGAINST --
THESE TERRIBLE WILDFIRES THAT
ARE --
STATESMAN FACING --
HOWEVER ALONG WITH CONSUMER
GROUPS THE REALTORS IN THE
BANKING AND THE MORTGAGE
INDUSTRY HAVE WORKED OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS TO COME UP WITH A
SET OF REFORMS ONE OF THEM IS
YOUR BELT --
THAT ADDRESS SOME OF THESE --
ALLEGATIONS OF CONSUMERSEEN IN
THE INDUSTRY --
WHILE STILL MAINTAINING THE
HEALTH OF THIS INDUSTRY BECAUSE
WE DO SEE IT AS A VALUABLE
PRODUCTS --
THE LEGISLATURE IS STILL
CONSIDERING TWO PIECES OF
LEGISLATION AS I MENTIONED ONE
OF THOSE IS YOURS --
ALSO THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT WILL BEGIN ITS RULE
MAKING PROCESS THIS NEXT YEAR TO
REGULATE THIS PREVIOUSLY
UNREGULATED INDUSTRY.
AND GIVEN THAT THIS IS AN
INDUSTRY INFLUX WHICH HOW SPACE
SCRUTINY IN THE PAST WE ARE HYDE
PARK DO WE ARE JUST HARD PRESSED
TO SEE HOW NOW.
IN THE LAST FEW DAYS OF THIS
SESSION IS A GOOD TIME TEXT IT
EXPAND THIS PROGRAM AND WE HAVE
TO ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE TODAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THIS
OPPOSITION MADAM CHAIR VERY
BRIEFLY PAUL YODER AND PINCH
HITTING FOR KAREN LANE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY TREASURES
AND TAX COLLECTORS BUT THERE'S A
LITTLE IRONY.
IN THIS BILL AND I WANT TO GIVE
THE MEMBERS --
JUST EVERYBODY A PROTEST.
IF YOU GET.
YOU YOU FINANCE SOMETHING
THROUGH PACE ESPECIALLY
SOMETHING FOR A FIRE HARDING
PURPOSE MAKE SURE YOU ASK YOUR
INSURER. TO COVER IT BECAUSE
THEY WON'T ON THE NATURAL IT'S
NOT LIKE PM I IT'S NOT AND
IRONICALLY IN SEVERAL PARTS OF
THE STATE.
PEOPLE HAVE HAD THEIR HOUSES
BURNED DOWN.
WITH PEACEFUL MEANS ON THEIR
HOUSE.
THAT THEY STILL HAD TO PAY OFF
AND I AM I THINK A LOT OF THE
MEMBERS ARE AWARE OF THAT BUT I
JUST WE FEEL LIKE WE CANNOT
EMPHASIZE IT TO YOU ALL.
ENOUGH THANK YOU I BELIEVE WE
GOT THAT IN THEMSELVES.
THAT'S CORRECT IT'S A PART OF
THE AMENDMENTS FROM YESTERDAY
THANK YOU FOR THAT POINTING THAT
OUT GET RIGHT.
I ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
MINIATURE CREEK PAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE SITUATION.
FOR MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE MENTIONED EARLIER CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE IS THE PACE IS
BOOMING AND WE'VE SEEN A
TENDENCY OF CONSUMERS TO BE
CONFUSE AND ASK ROSE.
TO HAVING TO PAY OFF OF THEIR
REFINANCING I MEAN THE BILL
UNABLE TO REFINANCE HAVING TO
PAY OFF THE LOAN BEFORE THEY CAN
SELL THEIR THEIR HOUSE AND THEN
OFFICE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE BEING
S. RECENTLY CAME THROUGH
RECESSION WERE THERE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO VOTE MORE IN.
THEIR HOMES AND THEY WERE WORTH
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT AS A
DOWNTURN THE MARKET OF AS THE
GOVERNOR HAS WARNED US ALL ABOUT
IN HIS BUDGETING.
THAT WILL HAPPEN AND HOPEFULLY --
WORSE WERE SOMEWHAT CONCERNED
ABOUT PEOPLE BEING OVER EXTENDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY -- IS
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
YES UP ASSEMBLY MEMBER COMING
ERA.
SO I I'M I'M NOT SURE I HAVE A
QUESTION AS MUCH AS A COMMENT
TONIGHT I AM [inaudible]
HAD A BASED ON THAT.
DIED SOMEWHERE LAST YEAR.
NOT SURE WHERE BUT BUT I WAS IT
THAT I WAS --
SPONSORED BY IS THE AT TAX
COLLECTORS AND THE ASSESSORS AND
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE
I'D QUITE FRANKLY IS THAT --
THE PREDATORY LENDING HAD LED --
TO SITUATIONS WHERE IN MANY
COUNTIES --
THE THE POSSIBILITY THAT PEOPLE
WERE GOING TO LOSE THEIR HOUSE
BECAUSE PASTE LOANS BECAUSE I
COULDN'T AFFORD THAT THE LOAN ON
THE HOUSE AS WELL AS THE PACE ON
WAS WAS VERY REAL AND AND WAYS.
IT IT IT FITS THE TSUNAMI --
THAT ARTICLE --
THAT.
THAT IT IT HAD THE POTENTIAL TO
HAVE A BUNCH OF LOW INCOME
MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE.
LOSING THEIR HOMES BECAUSE THEY
JUST WITH PREDATORY LENDING AND
THEY JUST DIDN'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
THAT -- THE
MECHANISM OF OF IT AT THE PACE
SLOW MOVING INTO THE FIRST ITEM
FIRST POSITION.
AND AND AND PEOPLE WILL SAY WELL
NO IT WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
HAPPEN AND I'VE TALKED TO THE
PEACE PROVIDERS HOWEVER THE WAY
THAT THE TAX COLLECTORS DO THEIR
ASSESSMENTS --
THEY GOTTA WAIT FIVE YEARS AND
SO IT'S A PROCESS WHERE --
THE THE THE DELINQUENCIES MOUNT
THEY BECOME INSURMOUNTABLE AND
AND THEY HAVE TO WAIT FIVE YEARS
BEFORE THEY CAN START TAKING
OVER THE HOUSE THE HOME SO.
THERE MAY NOT BE ANY RIGHT NOW
BUT GET BUT IT'S COMING AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT --
I AM VERY I'M VERY COGNIZANT OF
THE NEED TO GIVE PEOPLE AN
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO GET IN AND
MAKE THAT THE CHANGES THAT.
THEY THEY CAN ABOUT I'M REALLY
CONCERNED THAT --
THAT IN MANY MANY INSTANCES --
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DUPED INTO --
DOING THIS CHANGES SO I'M NOT
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY --
I DON'T WANT TO SEE IT --
DYING THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE BUT
YOU KNOW I JUST DON'T SEE IT BUT
I'M NOT SURE THAT I FEEL
COMFORTABLE WITH IT ON THE FLOOR
IN A MAYBE I CAN TALK.
TO MADAM CHAIR AND SEE WHAT HER
BELT.
YOU KNOW HOW IT IT STARTS TO ON
SET UP SOME OF THE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE LENDERS
AND AND A RECOGNITION THAT AT
SOME POINT SOMEBODY'S GOTTA BE
DETERMINING WHAT'S THE INCOME.
IT OF THIS HOUSEHOLD AND WHAT IS
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY FOR
ADDITIONAL WORK ON ON THEIR HOME
AND WHAT KIND OF ADVICE MINTZ DO
THEY NEED TO RECEIVE SO --
I I'M I'M VERY COGNIZANT REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE OPPOSITION
SOME SHOWING UP BECAUSE IT SOME
OF THE SAME BUT FRANKLY I HAVE A
STAFF FOR COMPLETION OF NO --
BUT I ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT ON
GIVING HAVING MORE TOOLS IN THE
TOOLBOX IS IMPORTANT BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER WE'RE
DOING IN TERMS OF THE PACE GOING
FORWARD.
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING CONSUMERS
IN IT AND IF I MAY I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU AND I'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR ON THIS
SO THAT'S WHY I A DECIDED THAT
EXPANDING PAYS TO ALLOW FOR
FINANCING OF HOME HARDENING
PROJECT.
SHOULD ONLY BE ALLOWED.
A IF WE ALSO REQUIRE ROBUST
UNDERWRITING.
A WHICH IS WHY I'VE MADE THE
BILL CONTINGENT UPON THE
PROVISIONS OF YOUR CHAIRS AB.
TWENTY SIXTY THREE ARM.
THIS IS WHAT WE DON'T WANT TO
COMPOUND THE FELONY AS THEY SAY
SO THIS BILL IS CONTINGENT ONLY
UPON CLEANING UP THIS PROCESS
THROUGH THE PACE OF REFORM BILL
THAT THE CHAIR HAS INTRODUCED.
AND ALSO IF I'M NOT MISTAKEN
THERE WAS A BILL LAST YEAR THAT
STARTED THIS MOVEMENT TOWARDS
CORRECTING THE PROBLEM AND AGAIN --
I DON'T I DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS
PROGRAM UNLESS WE HAVE THESE
ADDITIONAL A PROTECTIONS WHICH
IS WHY THE THE BILL IS
CONTINGENT UPON THESE
PROTECTIONS RATING IN PLACE I'M
GLAD TO HEAR THAT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE SESSIONS STARTING
FROM BOTH SIDES HERE SOON SO I
WON'T TAKE A LOT OF TIME OUTSIDE
OF THE FACT.
THANK YOU FOR THE BILL --
FOR THE CONCERNS FOR FIRE AND
THE HARDENING.
I CONCUR AND SHARE MUCH OF THE
SENTIMENT WITH MY COLLEAGUE AND
WILL SUPPORTING GETTING OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE BUT AGAIN SHARING
THE CONCERNS.
WE'LL REEVALUATE WHEN IT GETS A
FOUR BUT THANK YOU FOR BRING IT
FORWARD THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
STILL THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE FOR
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION ABOUT IT
CONSUMER PROTECTION IS SORT OF A
PASSION OF MINE ARE AYE THE
APPRECIATE THOSE CONCERNS AND
CERTAINLY --
INVITE THE CHARITY POINT --
WELCOME HER A ASSURING YOU THAT
THIS THIS BILL.
DOESN'T MOVE UNLESS WEEKS SHE
THOSE REFORMS THAT ARE BASED
UPON THE CHAIRS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY ANY OTHER COMMENTS --%
BEFORE YOU CLOSE ALL JUST SAY A
FEW THINGS I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
YOU KNOW I WAS VERY APPREHENSIVE
INITIALLY BECAUSE I REALLY
WANTED TO KEEP FOCUSED ON THE
BOTTOM MIGHT.
BUT MY PIC PACE BILL --
AND I THINK IT'S THE AS TIME
WENT ON I GAVE US MORE FUN I
THOUGHT.
THIS IS A GOOD TIME TO PUT THIS
THROUGH --
HARDENING IS A HARDING'S A
REALLY IMPORTANT THING THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE --
NICE TO SUPPORT THE WHOLE IDEA
BUT BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING
CONVERSATION THAT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED FOR THE LASTYEAR TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS MEANINGFUL
STATEWIDE OVERSIGHT OF THE PACE
PROGRAM --
AS YOU KNOW I HAVE MY OWN
LEGISLATION ON PACE WHICH MAY MY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE SIGNED ON
AS CO AUTHORS.
MY BILL MAKE CERTAIN THAT IT
HOMEOWNERS ABILITY TO PAY FOR
HOME OFFICIALS HE PROJECTS.
FULLY VERIFIED BEFORE I WANNA
SAY BEFORE THEY SIGN THE
ASSESSMENT OR HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACT.
AND BEFORE WORK ON THE
IMPROVEMENT ACTUALLY BEGINS AND
SO I APPRECIATE THE TIME THAT
YOU SPENT ON THIS --
A SENATOR --
I THINK THAT WE REALLY HAVE TO
HELP OUT IS A HOMEOWNERS AS WELL --
LET'S SEE WHAT ELSE I SO I WANT
TO JUST PUT THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE'VE DEVELOPED AND PUT IT INTO
THIS BILL.
A TEN YEAR SUNSET AND THE
INCLUSION OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS ON WILDFIRE SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS.
LIMITING THE BILL TO THOSE AREAS
THAT HAVE BEEN DOES DESIGNATED
AS VERY HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES.
ENSURING THAT THESE IMPROVEMENTS
WERE IMPROVEMENTS ARE JUST THAT
IMPROVEMENTS TO AN EXISTING
STRUCTURE BUILDING OUR HOME.
AND WILL NOT BE USED AS A WAY TO
DO RECONSTRUCTION ARE REBUILDING.
AFTER A DISASTER AND ENSURING
THAT THE PROPERTY OWNER KNOWS
THAT IT'S HIS OR HER
RESPONSIBILITY TO CONTACT THEIR
INSURANCE PROVIDER TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE WELFARE SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT TO BE FINANCED BY
THE PACE ASSESSMENT IS COVERED
BY THE INSURANCE PLAN.
BUT THOSE CHANGES I'M PLEASED TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM MUCH SHARE IT
WITHOTHER CLOSE MEMBERS VERY
BRIEFLY I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK ON THIS I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD BILL. TO DEAL WITH A
PROBLEM THAT WE'VE GOT TO
ADDRESS SOONER RATHER THAN LATER
ON I'M REMINDED THE ESCROW
OFFICERS TO REALTORS THEIR
CONCERNS.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY BUSINESS
OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ANY HOMES.
AND SO ARE WE TRIED BALANCE THIS
AS BEST WE CAN TO PROTECT THE
CONSUMER. TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
OF THESE CONCERNS ARE ADDRESS
WHICH IS WHY THE BILL IS
CONTINGENT UPON THOSE REFORMS
TAKING PLACE.
AND WITHOUT ON BEHALF OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND I SUSPECT THE
PEOPLE AROUND THE STATE.
AS WE LOOK AT WHAT'S GONNA COME
NEXT -- THIS
IS A REALLY CRITICAL WAY FOR AS
TO EMPOWER OURSELVES TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE THE THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE'RE SEEING IN OUR STATE
TODAY WITH THAT I'D ASK YOUR
IPHONE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSING
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ACT WHERE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM
CABALLERO CUMPLIR AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO REAVIS.
REVERSE I'VE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THIS REYES --
WILL DO IN ITEM NUMBER FOUR IS A
BE FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE WELL
WELCOME I'M.
I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA.
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR WORK BY
THE WAY THE BEEN DOING ON THE
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
I LAST YEAR CONGRESS PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT MADE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
FEDERAL TAX CODE WHICH AMONG
OTHER IMPACTS CREATED
OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND I'M SURE
YOU ALL HAVE.
TAKEN TIME TO IDENTIFY ALL OF
YOUR OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
THE GOAL OF THESE STONES TO
ADDRESS POVERTY IN LOW INCOME
AREAS SPECIFICALLY THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF OPPORTUNITY
FUNDS.
INVESTMENTS THROUGH THIS
MECHANISM ALLOW.
THE ENTITY OR THE PERSON TO
ELIMINATE FEDERAL TAXES ON
UNREALIZED CAPITAL GAINS AS AN
INCENTIVE TO INVEST.
IN DESIGNATED ZONES IN APRIL THE
US DEPARTMENT OF TREASURY
CERTIFIED CALIFORNIA'S NOMINATED
OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
DESIGNATING EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE CENSUS TRACKS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE ELIGIBLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THIS PROGRAM.
AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE SIMPLY
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING A CITY OR COUNTY
PARTICIPATING IN A TRANSACTION
INVOLVING PUBLIC PROPERTY. TO BE
PROVIDED WITH BASIC INFORMATION
RELATED TO THE PROJECT'S
DEVELOPMENT.
THIS INFORMATION INCLUDES THE
TIMELINE FOR THE COMPLETION OF
THE INVESTMENT ACTIVITY.
THE NUMBER OF LOCAL JOBS IS
ESTIMATED AND WORKFORCE
UTILIZATION STRATEGIES A. B.
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE ENSURES THE
PRIOR DOES PRIORITIZATION.
A PUBLIC BENEFIT WHEN THERE IS
PURCHASE OR LEASE OF PUBLIC LAND.
AND WITH THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
BUT ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
NO MOTION AND A SECOND --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES SIR AS A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE.
A AS YOU HAVE INTRODUCED YOUR
FELLOW I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
INTRODUCE AMR RASHEED WHO'S BEEN
A FELLOW IN OUR OFFICE HAS DONE
A MAGNIFICENT JOB.
HAS BEEN PART OF THE TEAM FOR
THIS ENTIRE TIME AM VERY PROUD
TO HAVE HAD HIM.
AND I'M SORRY THAT THIS IS ALSO
THE END OF THE WHY CAN'T WE HAVE
FELLOWS FOR TWO YEAR VETERAN
ABOUT A HOME --
BUT I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE TO YOU ABER RASHID.
WHO HAS BEEN GREAT FELLOW?
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
AND I RESPECT THE FACT YOU A
KNOWLEDGE DURING FELLOW THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL YOU'VE
DONE FOR MYSTERY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RANTS.
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION HAS TO CONCURRENT SENATE
AMENDMENTS ACT WHERE CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON BLOOM
CABALLERO CUMPLIR AYE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE GRIEVOUS [inaudible]
REVERSE I VOEPEL NAY
[inaudible]
VOEPEL I WALDRON OUR NEIGHBOR.
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALRIGHT WE HAVE A
LITTLE BREAK IN THE ACTION LOOKS
LIKE THIS.
WHO RUN AWAY?
FOR SENATOR MCGUIRE
.
WILL GO AHEAD AND DO THE ADAMS
RIGHT NOW SO.
SECRETARY.
ITEM TO SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY
FIVE JACKSON WALDRON.
LATINO.
ITEM.
THREE AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE CHU
WALDRON [inaudible]
I LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY I THAT'S IT FOR RIGHT NOW
.
THAT'S RIGHT.
NOW.
A LOT HAS ONLY
HER MCGUIRE.
S. IS THE ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B.
ONE FIVE WHO.
YEAH I THINK SO MUCH RENDON
SHARING GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
KNOW THIS IS A CRAZY WEEK WILL
MAKE IT VERY QUICK [inaudible]
I THE CHAIRS VERY FAMILIAR ABOUT
HOW BAD THE FIRES WERE IN THE
NORTH BAY LAST YEAR.
I IN FACT HERE THE WORST
WILDFIRE IN MODERN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY.
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED HOMES WERE
LOST COUNTY WIDE SIX THOUSAND
THROUGHOUT NORTH BAY REGION.
FIFTY THREE HUNDRED CINEMA
COUNTY ALONE.
FRAGILE WATERSHEDS WORD
DECIMATED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
HONESTY ONE FIFTY TWO WHICH
WOULD ALLOW VOTERS WITHIN CINEMA
COUNTY DECIDE WHETHER.
THEY WANT TO INCREASE THE SALES
TAX TO ADDRESS LOCAL NEEDS AND
WE HAVE AYE SUPPORTERS WILL BE
VERY BRIEF MADAM CHAIR GREAT
WELCOME --
IN SUPPORT PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SPEAK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRWOMAN --
MY NAME IS STEVE BAKER I'M THE
FIRE CHIEF FOR CINEMA VALLEY
FIRE AND RESCUE AND A MEMBER OF
THE FIRE SERVICES ADVISORY
COUNCIL PLANNING GROUP.
WHICH ADVISES THE CINEMA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS ON ISSUES
RELATED TO FIRE SERVICES.
I'D LIKE --
TO FIRST OF ALL THANK SENATOR
MCGUIRE THE NORTH BAY DELEGATION
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD --
SINCE THE DISASTER GROUP IS
FOCUSED ON CREATING A
COMPREHENSIVE FIRE SERVICE
DEPLOYMENT PLAN TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY EFFECTIVENESS AND
SUSTAINABILITY OF FIRE SERVICES
AND SONOMA COUNTY.
THIS PLAN WAS PRESENTED TO AN
APPROVED BY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS ON AUGUST FOURTEENTH.
S. B. ONE FIFTY TWO WOULD ALLOW
COMMUNITY MEMBERS THE ABILITY TO
VOTE ON INCREASED OPTIONS TO
FUND CRITICAL FIRE SERVICE NEEDS
THROUGHOUT OUR COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS MICHAEL
BOSKIN DEPUTY COUNTY
ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE COUNTY OF
CINEMA.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTES WILL OUR COMMUNITY
INCREASED OPTIONS TO FUND THESE
CRITICAL.
THINKING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT THING
THEN UP OF THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
YES MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
MORNING GIVEN WILL FOR THE
HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION I'M OPPOSED TO ASK
YOU.
ONE FIFTY TWO AND MEMBERS WERE
CONCERNED.
AND ONE OF THE CAR THIS DOESN'T
INCREASE TAXES IN AND OF ITSELF
BUT MERELY ALLOWS.
FOREIGN AUTHORIZATION OF TAX
INCREASES AND MORE CONCERNED AS
WE HAVE BEEN FOR A NUMBER YEARS
THAT THIS DOES SET A DANGEROUS
PRECEDENT INCREASED TAXES ABOUT
EXISTING AUDIT YOU PERCENT
BRADLEY BRINGS RATE HAS BEEN IN
PLACE. FOR DECADES NOW IT'S BEEN
IN PLACE FOR REASON CITIES AND
COUNTIES SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
EXCEED IT BASICALLY IT WELL AND
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED THAT'S
WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH DOZENS OF
EXAMPLES OF THE LAST COUPLE OF
AT LEAST OF THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS --
APPROACH UNIFORMITY KEEPS TAXES
REASONABLE AND WHEN WE'RE
DEALING WITH HER AGGRESSIVE
SALES TAX INCREASES --
DISSIPATE THE COUNTY OF CINEMAS
OVERALL SALES TAX RATE OF VOTERS
WATER PROOF THIS WITH A TWO
THIRDS VOTE AT NINE POINT 125%.
AND WE JUST THINK THAT'S
DRAMATICALLY HIGH --
FOR A VERY REGRESSIVE TAX RATES
SELL ASPIRIN ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
SINGER AND OTHER QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION --
BY --
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL THE
SECOND BY --
SOME MEMBER GRAYSON US SECRETARY
WHICH I TO CLOSE.
WITH RESPECT VETERAN I DON'T
MENTION THINK FOR ALL YOUR WORK
BY THE WAY BEHALF AND NO THANK
YOU THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
THIS DISTRICT AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING A BILL TODAY --
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL MOTION
AS DO PASS AGUIAR-CURRY HI
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON.
WALDRON [inaudible]
WALDRON NO.
BLOOM CABALLERO.
COMEY EURO AYE GABRIEL GABRIEL I
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NO GRIEVOUS.
REAVIS AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO.
OKAY FIVE IT WAS. FIVE TO THREE
BILLS OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MAKES TRY HARD WORK ON THIS.
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
MISTER BLOOM PERFECT TIMING.
I GOT.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AND SENATE BILL
ONE FIFTY TWO MCGUIRE BLOOM
[inaudible]
BLOOM I ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
TO SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY FIVE
JACKSON BLOOM [inaudible]
BLOOM I ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE CHIU
BLOOM [inaudible]
BLOOM I WHEN I AM NUMBER FOUR AB
FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE RAY S. BLOOM
[inaudible]
BLOOM I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER BLOOM FREE IN YOUR WE
NEED TO TURN